[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the brown table of dim
lighting
we're taking you
on a journey that we've been on for many
months that's culminated in this
uh i was going to say huge tick-tock
project but basically it's in our minds
we put a lot of energy into this thing
that's just come out don't over sell it
we don't past friday but yeah as of the
recording of this
we haven't experienced
what you have now experienced which is
watching our
we we've been calling it hazel that's
what we call the project our hazel tick
tock our multi project multi-part one
night
scripted
horror comedy
series
i don't
when you're dealing with these new
mediums don't know exactly how to to
describe it but what we will say if you
are listening right now
and they are
did not already watch what we're talking
about because you're like you didn't
know about it or you're like i don't do
the tick tock thing
it will be more of an enjoyable
experience for you
if you
drop what you're doing and take the time
to watch it even if you're not a a
tick-tock person now at some point we
are going to post it on
depending on when you're listening to
this it will be on our the redline
youtube channel at some point just in
its full form
uh which will make it easier if you
don't want to use you know the tiktok
app but anyway we just suggest that you
go over and watch it i don't know it's
it's we're going to be talking about it
so it's a little over like 20 minutes of
your time
that you would have to devote to
the full
the full experience and that would it
would just be helpful to then come back
and be able to hear the discussion about
it i use the term ambitious in
in the creative realm it's something
that like we can get into all the
reasons why we decided to do it
there's a number of itches that we
wanted to scratch and boy i really want
to know what people think we can talk
about the anticipation that's another
part of this has been so fun but another
thing we want to talk about
kind of a larger
conversation than just the hazel project
is our relationship with tiktok
and you know having come up on youtube
having 15 years of
figuring out how to take what we want to
do and translate it into the particular
platforms where we can get traction and
where there's audience
and then the advent of tick-tock and
figuring out what what's what does
mythical on tick-tock mean yeah what are
the opportunities there
we've been through a lot of
challenges
as we've tried to figure that out so i
think that in and of itself can can be a
fun conversation so if you're an avid
tick talker or watcher of tick tock or
if you have nothing to do with it i
think there's going to be touch points
for all of us
to uh
figure out how
we interface with that plan because you
may find yourself you might be i think
this is our tendency maybe just because
of our age it's just like when a new
social media platform comes along you're
just like uh really like
this is the thing now like am i gonna
have to get an account and then at some
point based on your personality your
disposition and the way that you divide
your time there's a point there's a
threshold for most people in which they
either decide to swear it off and never
join or they finally give in and join
and i think that as middle-aged creators
there's an interesting with kids who
enjoy this medium sort of an interesting
conversation around
how do you make a decision to actually
go for it why do you do it what's your
approach what are you learning what are
you trying to accomplish right
but let's start with
just the idea for hazel and kind of what
was what was behind it what set the
stage
in your recollection because it was it
was many months ago yeah well it wasn't
first though let's do something for
let's do something scary there was
something
there was a conversation that was going
on in the background
which is as we've established
and we actually did a whole episode
about it earlier this year we we talked
about all the other things that we have
worked on
that you've never seen because it's
their ideas that are developed for
television
or movies
that it's a whole different process
outside of the digital media that we
kind of own and control
which is the thing that you're watching
right now which we don't have to ask
permission to make this podcast you want
us to approve it yeah those things where
you're writing scripts and trying to get
traditional stuff off the ground it's
they're
it's a long time coming and then it may
never show up no one may ever see it and
they're very frustrating for us even
right now like even
just so you know right now we're in the
midst of
working on
a couple of very exciting projects i'll
just go ahead and say one's uh i mean
we've got multiple tv shows that we've
tried to get off the ground and continue
to try to get off the ground but there's
a
another pilot that we have
completed and now there's a a feature
script the whole movie that we are
beginning to to write and so these are
things that we are passionate about and
there it's a fun process and we throw
ourselves creatively at them and
hopefully
one or multiple of them will be able to
be made and i think when you look at the
sort of the pie chart of our time when
you wonder like what do rhett and link
do like what do they do besides the
things that i see them do
there's a big piece of the pie that's
like doesn't result in things that you
see so because that's a it's frustrating
right it's it's frustrating to kind of
pour yourself into something so then so
i the conversation sort of shifted to a
place where it's like okay
yes we've got all this stuff we're
trying to do that may never get seen
we've got all this stuff that we already
do that does get seen on a regular basis
but is there an in-between can we put
one more thing on our plate which is the
in-between which is stuff that has a
high sort of creative experimental
quotient trying something new that is
more narrative maybe in in
in its description
is there another is there a place for us
to do that because we're developing this
narrative content
yeah how do we do some of that that
people can actually see and also do it
in a very self-contained
frankly cheap way that doesn't take a
lot of our time and doesn't take a lot
of money
so and also
then
is
structured so that it makes us part of a
different conversation
you know if you're if you're an avid
listener of ear biscuits if you're a
dedicated viewer of good mythical
morning if you're a fan of mythical
kitchen you can you can get involved in
those worlds and just kind of stay there
we're grappling with the challenge of
continuing to find ways to
reach out and introduce more people to
the world of mythical and the things
that we're doing people have an idea of
what an awareness of good mythical
morning and they might may dip in and
out of it but we also want to do things
that continue to remind people hey we're
we've still got ideas and we want to we
want to make things that
express ourselves and also
make us part of new conversations and
introduce us to
new mythical beasts and i think above
all
for for both of us it's
there's a creative passion
to
that we don't want to
because again you don't want to sit on
your hands you can just be honest
rest on your laurels yes we're the guys
who eat weird things on the internet and
do do things and you kind of see us in
the context of our friendship
maybe that could be enough for a lot of
people you know
for us i don't think it is because it's
like we got things that we want to
create we got worlds that we want to
bring out so
then the discussion started like what
does that look like because
we've had we've had a number of people
including like tv executives who say
things like guys if you have an idea for
something why don't you just make it and
put it on youtube right
and i i think there's a number of
reasons why we've been hesitant to do
that when it comes to narrative stuff
besides just like an occasional sketch
or whatever which we're not really doing
that much on youtube anymore
the reason why we are doing on tick tock
and we'll talk about that later the
reason being is that
with few exceptions people are not
really interacting with narrative
content on
on youtube
in
in a meaningful way right and you'd be
like well you guys could change that but
it's like that's a that's a tough hill
to climb what we were seeing is that you
know what
kind of in an early sort of youtube way
the the this early stage of tick tock
one of the things that's happening is
sketch comedy just to use a broad term
has sort of found a resurgence
in this place like
scripted
comedy
has found a home on tick tock and all of
a sudden people are engaged our kids are
engaging with it in a way that
they are not engaging with youtube in a
way that's much more broad than
if you were to apply that same statement
of sketch comedy to vine back in the day
yeah i never observed maybe i missed it
because we never got on the vine
bandwagon
i never observed a type of sketch that
i wanted to do
it was it was it was very short and
very tonally specific
and there's a there's a broad range of
content i mean there's there's all
all niches now seem to exist on tick
tock
i mean spiritual deconstruction tick
tock
as an example and christian tic-tock oh
yeah i mean
you name it it it's all happening there
and so there's like
it can melt into the world of podcasting
it can melt into the world of sketch
comedy it can melt into the of course
the world of
dance well and i and i was doing some
avant-garde
[ __ ] sorry all types of stuff i don't
remember so i i was kind of thinking i
was i was sitting there trying to figure
out like okay
is there a way in for us that kind of
makes it i mean honestly it was kind of
it was from a strategy standpoint in
terms of
yeah we could do something that was is
just like
just straight up comedy like classic
rhett and link sketch in a narrative
fashion we as you see we'll talk about
later we are doing classic retinly
sketch sort of individually on tick-tock
and learning a lot over there
but like how do we want to do something
that's more eventized and get people to
kind of drawn in
i think kind of separately from that i
just happen to because i tend i'm
personally interested in horror right
i'm a horror fan
and i kind of keep up with what's
happening in that world
but typically it's just movies i watch
horror movies and then i watch some
horror tv shows but mostly horror movies
and
i saw this article about horror tick
tock
but it was also like horror tick tock
horror instagram
and what i saw is that
okay first of all there's also like
there's that uh i don't know if you
remember a couple of years ago there was
maybe just a year ago there was a
twitter thread
where
it was a writer who said that they were
going to
a cabin in the woods to to write a movie
and they were like oh there's something
making noise outside and it was a
twitter thread
turns out that the whole thing from the
beginning was designed to be
it was it was designed to become a movie
or designed to be a story it was all it
was all made up to begin with and it was
narrative it wasn't it was a narrative
and i don't know if that tricked you i
don't know if that one ended up becoming
something but there's been multiple
twitter threads
not just horror twitter threads but
instagram
things and now tick tock stuff that is
either it's intended to live there first
and then become something bigger but
then on tick tock what i was seeing is
that a lot of people were doing there's
like this one
kid who did a used kid like a teenager
um
did a thing
last year where
they had like some they were acting like
something was going on in their
neighborhood like their neighborhood was
abandoned or there was some and it was
like oh once a day he would kind of do
like an update and it was like kind of
creepy but it was like a once a day
thing for a while and you're like is
this real is this not real
i'm kind of walking that line
but the thing that no one had done
is something that's more
like a series like some people have done
like here's one really creepy video and
this is what i do on my channel but it
was like oh is there like a
self-contained
multi-part series that happens over the
course of a
shorter time span
that actually feels like it's happening
in the platform like it feels like oh
this is
not taking something that was made for
something else and putting it on tick
tock but it's if someone were to do a
horror if somebody was something were to
happen to somebody that was a horrific
on tick tock and they were to post it
what would that look like and that's
what kind of opened up the conversation
about the specifics of hazel you just
said what if something were to happen
like a horrific like you just made
horrific a noun like a horrific thing
that's what no i think that's what this
is like this is a horrific this is a
horrific it's a terrific it's horror
tick tock well it's a riff it's a rift
talk
horrific talk oh that's what we're it's
a horrific talk we're contributing to
that
we've helped
hurricanes
horrific
talk horrific talk because it's fiction
tick tock
horror
and
fantastic no no i'm just putting
together horrific and terrific talk yeah
yeah that's good that works
well let's coin it
it we got to get better at saying it
i've got it
horrific talk horrific talk it's just
horrific and then horrific horrific and
then talk horrific talk horrific talk
you can say that way horrific tick-tock
horrific horrific horrific talk horrific
talk
we'll do that on our own terrific talk
okay i think i have it and so
yeah we're like okay if we
do this
we can have fun
with
our audience we can we can do something
to where we're gonna
we're gonna trick them we're gonna set
up this conceit of it being
we're gonna write record and produce a
song this is something that like
i remember back when live streaming
first started
and ustream was the platform that we
picked and we we started doing the
written link cast live every thursday
night
another thing that we would do because
we just wanted to experiment with the
new tool was we would do office hours
where on i think it was on friday
afternoons we would just broadcast and
whatever we were working on we would
explain to whoever wanted to
peep into it
and then sometimes we would write songs
and we would get
input from people in the chat room
and it would it would impact what we
were writing on this is 2008.
so
that kind of fed into this
idea of we're going to set the
groundwork of it being something that's
that's interactive
um and unscripted and we're just pulling
an all-nighter yep
that will be fun to experiment with
and then it will go into this place
where
we're taking people by surprise and
things are getting scary and it's it's a
scripted
horrific tick-tock it's a horrific talk
a horrific horrific talk horrific talk
yeah
you'll get it and i think people will
talk about this well hopefully that's
the reason we'll talk about it that's it
and we're going to get into talking
about the sort of the process but that's
the really interesting thing about
recording this podcast right now we're
recording it before it gets released
there's been so much conversation around
i mean are we doing something oh is this
stupid like hey are we completely
missing the point is this gonna fly i
think it's 11 parts i can't i can't
remember exactly what we massaged it it
was 13 at one point and it was 12 i
think it's not 11. i think we
doing that many videos over the course
of a couple of hours on tick tock like
are we like just directly violating some
principle of the platform shooting
ourselves in the foot are people going
to be like what are these guys thinking
i don't know where to start like is it
technically going to work like there's a
total disaster
yeah this could be disastock this could
be
i'm not going to say it it's going to be
a mistake i mean what do we really have
to lose but like while we're talking
about this or while you're listening to
this it could be that like yeah it
didn't work and no one cared
uh yeah which we're prepared for are we
or it could be um i'm not prepared for
it emotionally no of course not it was
like oh i i get what you guys were going
for and i appreciate it and like it and
i want more stuff like this or it will
lead to something else in this world or
beyond who knows
we're talking about it in complete
ignorance at this point we've done
enough things to know that once you put
something out there
sometimes it immediately becomes clear
that there's one thing that seems likely
obvious now that we didn't think of yeah
and i i do think we've thought enough
about it to know that this could just
not work on tick tock
logistically experientially like from a
user standpoint and the my main concern
i'll just speak out loud at this point
is that as you'll see when you watch it
as you i've already seen because you
stopped and you went and watched it um
and hopefully we've made it easy for you
to i think we've we've put this it's too
late to even say that we've already done
a series
why are you saying you can click on the
so you can watch it all in order that's
important we've labeled the parts anyway
see you're still you're still actually
trying to plan it it's done and we also
i have a lot of trauma over this whole
like multi-part thing and getting people
to watch things in order with the whole
gmm-22 thing yeah because of the
complete flop so anyway um
anyway the
if you start at part one
part one in and of itself is not this
giant clickable
optimized tick tock right yeah like
we're putting putting all this stuff on
tick tock some stuff it's working
unassuming so there's not this huge
funnel
it's designed so that once
[ __ ] gets weird
and
you know crows start dive bombing the
the glass door and then
you find yourself passing through a door
in our creative house
into the woods in a very
realistic transition like a totally
hidden transition that we can talk about
um
it
when it gets real that's when it begins
to matter people start to care and then
we're counting on them figuring out how
to go back to the beginning and figure
out what have i missed how did this how
did they how did this start happening
yeah why is this backwards walking
backwards singing creepy woman
uh abducting link and taking him into a
forest because that's the so the one
thing if i could if the if this didn't
work
and i'm gonna pin it on something one of
the things i could pin it on
would be oh you know what the first
part should have had the
um
the trappings of a viral tick-tock which
is actually something that when we wrote
this months ago we actually did not know
tick tock nearly as well as we do now
having thrown so much stuff up there and
learned all these lessons right so i'm
like oh man so we started with the we're
sitting down to write a song write it
with us that's not something that people
are going to be like hey tune in to
rhett and link's channel they're writing
a song with us yeah that's just i mean
the entry point for mythical beasts
they'll be excited yeah but it's not
going to be something that i think will
get the attention of anybody else but
what could that what could that have
been because the other thing we wanted
to do is we wanted to make sure that it
we needed to bring you into a
real place so it didn't need to start as
a sketch it was important that it
started as a
oh rhett link are actually doing this
the rhett and link that i know
are
doing something in real life that is
believable so when we began to introduce
the unbelievable elements we've sort of
brought you along and we've got you in
this place where you can be emotionally
manipulated for entertainment purposes
and this is one of the things that i
immediately got super excited about that
i think fueled our energy through the
entire project so let's get into that
after a quick add a quick ad check out
this pin
i've got it on my sweater you can put it
on your jacket you can put it on
anything and it spins it's this it's the
wheel and mythicality
and it is a pin
it says it's time to spin the wheel of
mythicality you can get one of these at
mythical.com
it's nice you can get two of them and
put them strategically over your
um
nips
don't put them in your nips though don't
unless you have an existing piercing
that would be cool
jenna's like no no do not give that
advice jenna's saying if you have a
nipple piercing you probably already
know what you can and shouldn't do to it
i mean maybe you can't put other things
it doesn't it doesn't have one thing
that it has two individual things so
you've got to pierce twice you'd have to
take the rod that's going sideways
through your nipple and create a new
thing for the pin to grab onto
so that the thing that's going through
your nipple is the thing that's always
going through your nipple
and the thing that you're adding to the
piercing is our thing don't put our
thing in your nipple
keep your thing in your nipple then put
our thing on the thing that's in your
nipple and everybody will be okay but it
is made for the nipples
indirectly
it is made for all nipples hey this is
what you get with the video version you
get an unhinged nipple ad from
mythical.com and you also
get clarity about hazel because now
the uh assembled version is live on
youtube
and skip over to the rhett and link so
for some reason you can you can watch it
all together you have resisted
you've resisted going over to tick tock
with the multiple
urgings that we have given now just go
to our go to the retin link channel and
watch the whole thing and then come back
and you'll enjoy this discussion even
more you know what time it is
the thing that i got so excited about
that you know there's a point in every i
get goosebumps now thinking about it
you get this
i always look for the spark
at the beg with the genesis of a
creative idea
a lot of times
you're bringing something to the table
you're a
take
make something out of nothing and i'm
more of take that something and shape it
into even more of a thing that's really
going to work
so
i find that my interactions a lot of
times are
learning how to
not filter any
your pitches but
um
champion
the the things that that i think are
working like where we get this
synergy
and for this one it really
was the
you know we were on the same page about
what we wanted to accomplish but when we
started talking about the experience
that we could give
to our audience
and it be
this
special surprise
that we could you know we pre-taped it
we've made it seem like we're doing it
basically live filming a little
something posting it and
making it happen in real time
of course you know we filmed it freaking
months in advance
so we we have the luxury
and the privilege of like having a front
row seat to what happens
on tick tock you know like seeing the
comments come in seeing over the course
of that second and third post fourth
post
people starting to realize
hold on this is not what i thought it
was we're not going to be writing a song
this is crazy this is scripted this is
this is a horror comedy thing
and
i'm i just have have been very excited
about
observing that experience and observing
in real time as an experiment in real
time how are people gonna respond how
how are mythical beasts gonna band
together and be commenting on the
mythical society discord on uh
twitter
obviously on
tock but forming these ad hoc
viewing parties where you're waiting for
the next post
because
it's a special experience for people who
are watching in real time
and we had this challenge of
promoting it and saying this is
something we're excited about it should
be fun but also downplaying it as
something that's just an interactive
having to say having to say
you're going to write a song with us and
so it's like if that didn't appeal to
you you're you may be out you're i'm not
going to get a tick-tock account for
that if i don't already have one but
there's this there's this real-time
experience with the people that
want to be there
and are able to be there as it's
unfolding yeah and they're making sense
of it was very exciting to me and then
there's this tick tock experiment of
getting
tick-tock viewers who are not first
mythical beasts coming into it and
seeing if we're right that they'll
figure it out and they'll be into it
even if they don't care about us and
then who knows man putting it somewhere
else and seeing if it can develo if if
people will enjoy it off platform and on
youtube i'll say again one of the
theories from the marketing side of this
thing and
did this work i don't know
is that okay it's one thing to just make
another horror movie right when you make
another horror movie you are
competing with everyone who's ever made
horror movies and everyone who is
currently making horror movies and
releasing horror movies
uh you're subject to critical response
etc marketing budget now with when you
do the expectations that everyone
approaches any horror movie with but
when you
do something on a platform like tick
tock i mean i always talk about how
i feel like
the only reason
that we're actual
successful in quotes comedians you
define that how you will we make a
living doing it um
we make a living is because we came up
through
the christian comedy world i'm just
going to be frank about it like if if
you ever funny in settings where people
didn't ex didn't require to expect or
demand you to be hilarious we kind of
gained bar was low we gamed the system a
little bit by developing in this bubble
in a place where we weren't competing
against any other comedians we were
competing against like maybe a funny
worship leader which is an easy target
and because we know that
that's one of the reasons maybe the root
reason why we have a chip on our
shoulder there's other reasons now and
how people view youtubers and creators
versus traditional celebrities but we
don't have to get it and so there is
this belief that if you
do something like this on a platform
like tick tock at a time in the
evolution of the platform like right now
there's a possibility that just having
made the
decision to do something that is this
ambitious and involved in this genre
that people care about
maybe
okay did we make did we make get out
hell no we did something that we shot in
two nights right we didn't make it we're
not we wouldn't be capable i'm not
saying we would you could give us all
the money in the world i'm not saying
we're gonna make a jordan peel movie but
we don't have to
we need to make something that people
are like that's cool
i was scared when i needed to be scared
i laughed when you guys wanted me to
laugh and you did something in a place
that i wasn't expecting it and so now
i'm actually talking about it because
you made the decision to put it here
there's a secret hope that that will be
part of the strategy yeah now the
specific the specifics of the idea i
mean
we were having a conversation at some
point where it was like hey what what if
what if it had something to do with an
album you know oh then we could make it
where we're at we're we're starting the
night singing and then
the specifics it's not like this is some
groundbreaking plot right this is a if
you want to be honest about it the
specifics of the way that this plot sort
of unfolds is like yes it's an intact
interesting
uh way of getting a get getting your
antagonist into your
monster into your house my this is a
monster in the house
movie to use that genre we needed a way
to do it like the ring where the girl
climbs out through the uh television
when you when you play a certain
whatever it was that was like a vhs tape
you made me watch it and i've tried to
wipe it from my memory ever since so it
had so yeah it had that sort of like
there's a vehicle in which this person
can get brought into your world
and that's where the whole hazel thing
came from and the hazel making of it all
like we we've talked before about how
we're it's v and i especially since i
watched a lot of horror movies very
scared of especially like a little girl
in a dress
like the the poltergeist deal that's
just something that is always kind of
freaking me out because you've got this
mix of what you perceived to be innocent
now there's the sinister side to it and
that's the classic horror trope
so it's like okay
could we make this like a woman in a
dress and then how do you go what kind
of music would you oh maybe something
like appalachian
and it just something that's haunting
but not
that doesn't read as horror immediately
it's like horror adjacent like if you if
you have the right album cover and you
write have the right song which we tried
to create
um you know
yeah we were
we were
leveraging
the fact that like i have a record
collection at the creative house it's
true to us
we've made records in the past so we
know knew that we had uh
our our team to make a vision knew how
to make a record and like actually
making a record that plays and that has
high quality packaging is a great way to
to to suck people into the story when
they still don't know it's a story
so we had those elements that we felt
like were working for us and we started
meeting with derrick furman who
uh produced our lionel covers and we've
and
worked very closely with my cousin
britain
great guy that we vibe with that
you know we started talking to him about
the project and he was really excited
about the experimental nature of it and
so
we went in there for a recording session
we we of course we knew we had to cast
the um we need to have a female voice
and then we needed to cast somebody to
play that
female and then jenna suggested paige
her you know who
she knew from what theater
uh uh right after college yeah uh
kentucky shakespeare kentucky
shakespeare yeah so you
jenna was recommending paige because
paige is in a band page is a vocalist
and we had worked with paige before we
even had met and started working with
jenna which is so strange so
uh
we brought paige in she recorded the
part for hazel
nailed it and she's also
an actor and can come in and play the
part so it was like a win-win and like
she was already in the mythical world
because
what we had worked with her on before is
buddy system
season one
uh
when
let's see there's the commercial for the
drain weaver yeah
which is
uh
you know our co-ex girlfriends who's now
became the media mogul with
billy mays type products including
all the hair that goes into your shower
drain if you put the right
mold down in in there
you can then after of an x number of
showers you can pull that out and it
will have an article of clothing that
has been magically woven from your uh
body hair in your head hair all of your
hair and we needed a model for that
commercial and the
the audition process was one of the more
awkward audition processes that i've
ever been a part of because it was
bringing in women into our office uh for
me
um
i the casting
director and it wasn't just
people but still sitting in our office
when you bring a a bunch of women one at
a time into your office and the thing
that they're doing for their audition is
acting like they're showering
um
and they don't have any lines that is uh
it gets we just we did not anticipate
how weird it was how awkward that could
get to watch women in our office
pantomime showering and then just kind
of sit there and like nod with a notepad
like oh yes she touches herself in a
what i mean it's like what do you do
when you shower you like you're like
touching you're you're bathing and
you're like reacting to scrub yourself
okay well i mean but well they were they
were touching themselves not in that way
like in a shower away
bathing themselves anyway paige did a
great job at that
paige seemed to understand she
understood the assignment because it
there was a voice over like
have you ever thought about all the hair
that you send down the drain and never
making the clothes and then you're like
yes you know so there's obviously it was
very comedic so you've got to like
respond to this she was yeah she was
doing she got it i'm in an infomercial i
will say uh it's been a long time so i
mean let's tell this story i don't think
there's any way that anyone's going to
be able to trace this back to this
particular person because there was no
record of who auditioned that day but
uh there was someone who did not
understand the assignment
uh
in two ways yeah the first way that they
did not understand the assignment is
that this particular woman thought that
she was auditioning for the role of amy
brels which had already been given to
leslie
the lead role in the entire series to
leslie bibb and the way we found out was
because when she came in
she started showering she did start
showering she did i don't know how she
put these two things together i don't
know what script she got a hold of but
then she she launches into a monologue
while showering which of course no one
has done because they don't have any
lines and then we realize she has
memorized leslie's line and amy brell's
monologue and we i mean again we're nice
guys we're good southern boys so we let
her go through the whole thing we were
like well she's going to do it less to
see how well she's prepared
uh maybe we recast i don't know who
spoke first to say ah great job on that
that's um that was really good
but actually
this role is just the shower girl
so can you do that all again without all
the stuff you memorized it felt i felt
so bad and i just no one else did it i
mean i don't think it was on us i have
to also say that her wardrobe choice
that day
um well i'll call it a cat suit it was
um
it was what you might expect if you if
you thought like oh this is a shower
scene
um in like a different genre maybe yeah
like if if you were gonna be nude in the
shower and you wanted to but you didn't
want you didn't want your audition to be
nude but you wanted to be like but just
so you will know what i look like
without clothes on
i'm wearing clothes that will allow you
to come to those conclusions there's a
suit for that yeah she had her there's
an article of clothing and she had that
on it was just very tight in every
single place and um
it gave the i guess it's what uh we did
learn a lot you would wear if you were
gonna be naked i don't know and the more
i think about it it was a strategic
choice not knowing where where it could
go yeah that's true she didn't get the
part paige did long story paige got the
part it's wild that like jenna knew
paige
from way back when then we met paige
then we met jenna and then jenna
reminded us of paige and then paige
comes in and like
had a great time yeah again it was weird
because like it's paige's vocals as
hazel
but then
we never see her face it's like we're
giving her this limitation like whenever
we cast into something for either you're
not going to talk at all
or
you're going to sing but we're never
going to see your face but it is paige
it is the back of her head uh and she
did an excellent job and if you know one
day we might put it together she might
have lines
we're not making choices about not
giving her lines or giving her face time
because of anything about her it's just
she happens to be involved in the
projects where that happens to be the
case one interesting thing about that
and about about paige is that of
course she was the focal point of all
of a lot of the horror you know you see
and we knew we had this idea about the
back masking of playing it back playing
the record backwards is the way that
sort of the portal opens up and that
plays into these sort of childhood fears
and and some of the stuff that we said i
don't actually remember a guy coming to
our church to talk about it but i think
it was maybe something that campbell
came to campbell yeah and he talked
about back masking and of course we
believed everything that anybody said to
us when we were kids especially in a
christian context so we were like yeah i
guess the devil is influencing led
zeppelin to
send messages through the records
backwards it was a seminar that i think
he had been doing for
over a decade yeah at that point and
it's like but we were still like
mesmerized by it so and that tends to be
and first of all
backwards
singing and talking is unsettling
for deep biological reasons i guess and
it's so it's very it is a very scary
thing so you're like how do you take
this biological reasons i'm just saying
that there's you're intrinsically scared
of backwards talking it's just weird and
you know you you you put it in the
context of this
dark house with this woman singing and
then we knew oh it's a threat she's
singing backwards
let's have her walking backwards and
then i think this is a good time to talk
about ben's
uh involvement in it so ben eck who
works for us has worked for us for a
very long time the only person that has
worked here longer is stevie because
this is the first person that stevie
helped us hire back for the mythical
show but ben
only worked for us like a week less than
steve yeah
very very soon after stevie and bennett
worked together at a previous job so
then she was like this is the guy i'm
bringing in yeah and uh yeah he's been i
mean he's he's instrumental on the
mythical kitchen side now you'll hear
uh josh and the team yeah talking to ben
but when we have ideas like this because
ben ben was there for all those classic
sketches music videos he was there for
buddy system
he understands what we're trying to get
across creatively and narratively which
again we don't do a whole lot of that
except writing and pitching at this
point so the making of the narrative
stuff it was like all right well let's
bring ben back into this process and get
him really involved he's gonna he's
gonna be essentially directing this
because we're gonna be in it the whole
time and he was essential yeah and as
the director and then i think the thing
about ben because he does have a lot of
filmmaking experience
is that
you know when he took a look at the
script
it was like hey here's my ideas for the
places that we could up the
the you know this is my idea for how we
could capture this to make it even
scarier this is you know were there even
crows hitting the window before you got
a hold of it yeah there was but
uh there was a lot of he had a lot of
thought on how to do that how to achieve
it ben's
ben's biggest
uh thing that he brings to the table
that we don't typically think about is
the until we get into it is the
you've got this idea
and you've written it
how do you capture it visually in a way
that will communicate what you actually
want to communicate to your audience and
especially in the horror genre which
again i've watched a lot of horror
movies and have a sense of what make of
the types of
themes and visuals and ideas that make
people scared
but translating that into and this is
how so in other words
so one of the ideas we had was we want
her to always be walking backwards but
ben was able to literally do
a test shoot where he's like the way to
make this super creepy is to put her
dress on backwards and to have her long
stringy hair which is not her hair it's
a wig
in front of her face so she looks like
she's facing away but her arms are
there's a little it's a little off and
then when she moves towards you
it's even freakier because her legs are
moving in a way as if she was walking
normally but she's facing backwards
whereas if you try this thing that
you're first thinking about which is
like let's just have her literally walk
backwards it kind of just looks like a
normal person walking backwards and all
of a sudden you're you're taken out of
it horror is difficult to do
as is comedy that's why there should be
more oscar
categories for each of those because it
is
a challenging art form to elicit those
type of responses
you know it's a lot easier to make
somebody cry
than it is to scare the [ __ ] out of
somebody or to make them pee their pants
laughing
in my opinion
speaking generally not specifically so
ben had to translate the script in in a
way that would okay the this is how
these are the moments where you've got
to get the scares and here's here's how
we're going to go for that
there's an added
challenge of working within
the rules of tick-tock and it being one
phone yeah literally shooting with a
phone we could have talked ourselves
into each having a phone but that's not
really how we would conduct
like the
you know writing a song all night on
on tick tock the thing that we said we
were doing we had to keep the conceit
um
true
right so we had one phone filming
vertically and then there's handoffs and
there's there's places where you would
stop filming and there's places where
you'd keep filming there's places where
you'd miraculously
keep filming while you were freaking out
it's like you got to take all these
things into account to make it as real
as possible
getting into those details
was so much fun
as with derek talking about the way that
he's going to export the songs so that
we can play them in the room versus
having to add them in post
so that there's proximity
when you're when you're moving the phone
around so if you listen with headphones
on if you you know that's a great way to
re-watch hazel because of the amount of
sound design because proximity
and sound location is a is a big part of
the story yeah as is things like
um and you knew this when you wrote it
in the second scene is that we've got to
establish the layout of the house
within the context of us writing a song
on tick tock so that later
the viewer understands
where hazel is coming from and where
she's taking me and taking you
um
you have to understand
spatially what's going on
so that you can to set you up to be
scared
so that you have expectations when
you're walking towards this door you
should be the most scared
as an example there's a lot of logistics
and details that go into
getting a certain response from an
audience and again that's what i can't
wait to see because in between clips
people hopefully people will be talking
about it
and
making sense of what's happening and
waiting for the next the next clip
minutes
later is again it's very difficult to be
genuinely frightened by something that
you wrote
um yeah now my so my process is always
okay
i i don't like to see
the first couple of passes of the edit
right like you you you were working with
ben
on that and i like to see it once it's
kind of like because i was like i'm very
intimately
sort of
like thinking about all this during the
writing process and then i kind of want
to
separate myself from it so i can be as
much of an audience member when i watch
it but that was really hard to do i mean
when i watched the first cut
there were moments where i began to feel
the
sort of frightened emotion that i knew
we were trying to go for but it's it's
just gonna be so much different for
somebody who doesn't know what's what's
gonna happen yeah uh and so that i'm
interested in that because that's the
beauty of the conceit is that it we've
set the stage for you to be the most
freaked out because it's not at all what
you're expecting it's kind of like when
i took christy to see get out and like
right before the movie started she
leaned over and she was like
is this
is this movie scary or
is it is this a drawing like she did not
it's the perfect way to go into a movie
i was like i don't i don't think you
should know you should just watch it
yeah you didn't want her to yeah get
scared pretty immediately interesting
dynamic
you know we when we were filming this
thing like i said we filmed over two
nights
the the the first night we filmed in the
woods
and then the second night we filmed in
the creative house and
uh
we we never do night shoots even
i think uh on buddy system season
one we did we did a nice shoot we did
one night shoot a couple maybe maybe a
couple
and um
it's difficult for us like i was kind of
nervous to like really like okay you
know your best time's night the whole
red bull and that whole scene
at the beginning we were really drinking
the energy drink i was drinking that
hippo piss or hippo whatever it was um
but you get into
you're out of there in the woods and uh
it's hard to shoot at night in the woods
when you're like having to trudge a
bunch of stuff
um a quarter mile down there of course
the team did most most of the trudging
i'll be honest
um
it was it was a lot of fun to be out
there in the woods at night and to take
a door frame and set that up like
literally that door frame was there
um
we didn't computer generate anything
most of the magic in the cuts happened
in swiss pans but the biggest point of
where you walk down the hallway and go
through that middle doorway and when you
open it
it's not the recording room like we
showed earlier but it's the
it's the forest
uh ben felt and we agreed that like we
want to take a door out there and we
want to do this practically and we don't
want to you know we frame the door close
enough
so that it's already in the woods but
you don't know it because of the way
that he's lit it
you open it up and then there's the
forest floor and it's all real like
there's no there was no chicanery in
post to make that happen
because
we built
like paisley came out there and they
built the door
frame yeah quick note about that like uh
everybody who worked on this thing with
the except exception of paige
was just you know a team team member
here at mythical that was kind of
stepping into something that they don't
always do jenna was involved on the
production side
um
paisley
built that
built that door which he's always
building stuff for gmm but it was
and then of course ben's kind of taking
time out of what he was doing on
mythical kitchen
so i think it was fun for us all to kind
of like get to do
something it's i mean it's fun it's
always fun for us to be like hey this is
something that's different and it's like
it's it's not this giant thing that
we're throwing ourselves in for into for
months and completely turning our
schedule upside down it's like hey this
is going to be a couple of fun nights of
working together as a very small crew i
mean i think we maximum had what like
six people there at one time
i think so yeah yeah yeah i mean just
super
mission accomplished on that front okay
maybe eight people it was it was fun
there was someone was attacked by a bat
is that right who was that it was it
just kept flying down like when paige
and i were when you all were filming
without paige yeah we left paige and
jenna back at the um at the porta potty
in the parking lot well we shot this at
the same location yeah we shot this at
the same location that we shot the uh
monkey snake which i don't remember the
name of that did you get me did you get
me anything so it was the the woods
up in the angelus
uh mount angelus national forest if
you're into the behind the scenes stuff
greg shot a bunch of behind the scenes
yeah it's on the mythical society so uh
you can you can see that visually but um
there was a bobcat sighting and it it i
think we wrapped i think i got in bed
that night at that morning five a.m yeah
like in
i got maybe i got home a little earlier
than you guys and but then the next
night
is when we we shot in the creative house
we shot and shot everything else yeah
that was the top that was literally yeah
we actually the last couple of shots we
had to
make sure that the windows were not
letting light in because we were
getting into the daylight
you know
stevie also being there was
very helpful i remember one instance
when we're shooting at the creative
house the first few scenes of like
setting up
the farce of it being an interactive
songwriting thing like the the first few
scenes where we're like supposed to be
totally ourselves
and we don't want to give any inkling
that we're we're acting like the actor
versions of ourselves there's this weird
thing that happens that we
we had to face which was
we've gotta
we've gotta be ourselves i mean we've
gotta be like really in like vlog gmm
mode and at some point
we're going to be going off of a script
and we're going to be making that
transition to
still acting like ourselves but in now
we're really acting we're doing
something that wouldn't happen to us
yeah in this real world reacting to
things that wouldn't happen to us so
it's great to have
like stevie and ben there who are like
you need to play this scene
like rhett you would respond to lincoln
this way
behind the desk at gmm and i don't feel
like you're doing that or
you're giving me similar direction where
it was and i think that's a big test is
if
if people watch the first few clips and
they're like why are they acting weird
then
i'm pretty confident that that
might be good about it my main concern
is that they're just most people are
gonna be like i don't really care about
you guys
bringing me along the ride to write a
song but i'm saying that from a
performance standpoint it was
it was a fun challenge to think of it
that way that we're making this
performance transition from completely
or very loosely scripted to pretty
tightly scripted yeah yeah so every
aspect of it
was
was challenging in its own way that was
part of why we wanted to do it you know
just to like scratch those itches and uh
get the creative juices flowing and we
do think i mean i i'll i'll say that i
also have a secret hope that
um in the way that some of these
twitter threads
and whatever they might be things that
start kind of small on on the internet
like there is a world here to explore
not necessarily the exact thing that we
explored but the concept of uh the album
and being trapped in an album and it's
been there forever like what's the
origin story of that like i would love i
would love to be able to tell that story
not necessarily as a buddy comedy with
the two of us who knows but
so i i really hope people love it now
one thing that happened that to speak to
the
the nature of doing this
on tik tok in a platform that we're
learning
is you know we had this idea for this
scene with the crow where the crow hits
the
the door
and then we go outside and we see it and
it's dead and there's a moment that we
have with it that ends with me throwing
it away and link accusing me of
littering and then by the way if you
look at the album closely
like rewatch it and look at the album
yeah anytime the album is shown it's
very intentional and yeah it will change
maybe in ways that you did not
anticipate or see the first time but
we were we had this we had this
replica crow
and we're out there seemed like it was
the weight of a crow it was very good
and i'm out there and so putting this
towel over and that's when greg who was
doing the behind the scenes and also
works on our social media and knows more
about tick tock than we do
was he just kind of says in the moment
he's like
yeah i hope that that
i hope that this part of it is not
misinterpreted because sometimes on tick
tock if things are if people think that
you're doing something with the you know
it's conceivable that if people thought
you were doing something with an actual
dead animal
that people could get upset and they
could pull that that video down yeah
really throwing a dead crow
in the woods
there was actually a there was a scene
so at that point we were like okay well
what is scripted what you've planned to
do and even what we shot test footage of
was you picking up the crow and you
making fun of me for saying i think
it'll come too just give it a minute and
you pick it up and i'm like what are you
doing you're like well i'm going to give
it a toss and see if it'll give it a
little head start give it a head start
on full give it a jump start like a
paper airplane and you throw it and it
just plops down on the concrete and it's
hilarious it's very funny
and then you pick it up again and that's
when we talk about the rotisserie
chicken and you you throw it in you say
test footage i mean we shot that as a
scene we have that intact which we are
probably showing to you right now
what are you gonna do with it
i don't know maybe he'll come back too
if i give him a little jump start like a
paper airplane
no
dude
he's freaking dead man okay
hold on wouldn't that be littering we're
having a debate in the moment of is that
too much is throwing the crow and having
it plop down people the risk of people
thinking it's a real crow and getting
upset
tick tock may be flagging it and like if
you remove this this one clip from the
whole thing is that then confusing and
frustrating yes and it's like so we you
know we're like well let's just shoot
another version
of this particular scene where you don't
plop it on the ground you just throw it
in the woods and maybe that'll mitigate
it and we'll decide later
so but yeah because it's so experimental
you get in your own head of like what is
the thing that we're forgetting that's
gonna bring this whole thing down and i
remember at that moment there was a bit
of a crisis if that becomes the reason
that this doesn't work that sucks and so
yes we so the tone down version is in is
in there
um
so we're not concerned about it at this
point it's not again it's not as funny
it's not as funny as me throwing the
crow up in the air and having it hit the
ground but again for that that could be
it's dead animal humor maybe people
don't like that anyway
it wasn't it wasn't necessary so you
know it's a matter of taste
yeah if not a matter of uh
like
content restrictions and flagging which
we
got a
reasonable certainty that it wasn't
but let's let's skip to tick tock at
large
i think that
this is obviously a strategy but
in parallel because we've been
developing hazel for many months
we're also trying to figure out what's
our general tick tock strategy
because
we're
the the audience that's over there is
undeniable and so we made a decision
was it pre-pandemic yeah because we were
in the boardroom i remember that's right
i remember the moment we were all
sitting together are we gonna do tick
tock is mythical going to be
are we really going to try this are we
going to are we going to allocate
resources to this where there's there's
no money in it there's no direct
revenue sharing
so it's hard to justify from a financial
business standpoint but from a strategic
standpoint we said
this i mean
this is not a flash in the pan this is i
specifically remember
thinking and saying i think in that
moment when we were considering it
like i don't want this to be
there are these moments in the birth of
social media platforms in which your
ability to get traction
like right in the beginning like you
remember all those people like ashton
kutcher how does he have so many twitter
followers
well he got in and he took it seriously
from the beginning
now if you're just like i think i'm
gonna get on twitter like
getting
a twitter follower these days and
keeping it as someone who's been
pretty much the same number for a really
really long time it's so hard this at
this stage in the platform
but i was like if we get in now even if
the only thing we're doing because i
think what we said is let's just get on
there and let's just put some gmm clips
on there like let's just have a presence
because getting on there and letting
people know that you're there even if
you're not yet doing anything strategic
you're gonna get followers and that
worked and we got to a million followers
pretty quickly and it was like okay good
all right we're we have a foothold here
on this thing that seems like it's going
to be important in the larger sort of
conversation but then it was like what
are we actually going to do and me and
you in the beginning of the pandemic
because i remember was talking about
this uh when we were doing our vlogs
we actually started to record
for a potential vlog on the retin-link
channel when we were doing those
the process that we were coming up with
because a lot of people were like what
is happening on the mythical tick tock
like what are rhett and link doing who's
writing these tick tocks so we wanted to
do a retin-link vlog
where we
talked about our experimentation
on tick tock and documenting that
process but then it became it became a
lot to figure out what we wanted to try
on tick tock
personally and then to have to document
it ourselves
it just became a bit much but the thing
that we were doing that you may have
noticed if you like if you've been
watching us for a really long time you
may have picked up on this
now yes there are a lot of things that
we sort of do as a company that link and
i lend ourselves to and kind of throw
ourselves into and you can and you might
be like i don't know if that's something
that rhett link would have come up with
but i can see why they did it or or
whatever we threw ourselves into tick
tock on a very personal
like level
and kind of went back to that initial
mentality of
the early days of youtube in which we
were creators trying to figure out a new
platform throwing things out there
experimenting throwing a lot of things
at the wall getting reaction
now that's not a full-time thing for us
because of all the other stuff that we
do but when we engaged with it over the
past year and a half or so
that's how we would do it we would like
let's learn all we can listen and then
the the team was also developing things
that we could that mythical could try on
our tick tock but what we were doing at
the creative house was like we were
getting down on all fours and filming
each other as dogs as dogs yeah or as
these like strange superheroes having a
video conference yeah we were just
trying some character-based stuff
uh i can't remember what else we tried
but then we
also just some straight-up sketch stuff
and a lot of this still is on some of it
was taken down because it just didn't do
well a lot of it is still on there from
over a year ago that kind of fizzled out
i think we got distracted or pulled into
other things and it didn't take off so
it got a little it didn't really work
got disheartening yeah and there were
other things that were working
and then when we came back to it
many months later we started doing some
uh
some sketch based stuff
but
we wanted to hone
and we're still in the process of honing
what
mythical sketches
what rhett and link sketches on
tick-tock look and feel like
and so we're like we want them to be
conversational we don't want him to you
know we don't we
we learned we didn't want to go too prop
heavy or we didn't want to we wanted to
be able to turn these things out quickly
we have to be super
the engineer and us but also just the
very busy people in us we have to be
super efficient with everything we do so
we really need to be able to shoot one
of these tick tock sketches in about
you know 15 or 20 minutes but it's
shocking how you can upload something
and it will get like thousands of views
and then you can upload something else
and it can get
millions if not tens of millions and
they can be right next to each other and
no influence on one another so we're
doing right now we're doing sketches
we're doing trends tik tok trends and
we're doing like
gmm clips that can be
tick-tockized
so where they actually work for that
platform and don't feel just like an
exported clip and as we record this
right now like we've actually again our
team is great i i don't want to miscarry
when i say that we've thrown ourselves
into this i'm just saying that like
we've really gotten involved on the
creative side but that doesn't mean
we're doing it all our team is doing
right so much good work and at this
point the creative process is like we've
got our internal team pitching and
writing we've got we actually have some
uh outside writers who make their own
tick tocks that we like that are that
are pitching and writing sketches we're
pitching and writing sketches ourselves
and and it's just become this sort of
like old school collaborative let's see
what people respond to but
as of like right now as we record this
we're getting some reaction like we're
getting it feels like p some people are
literally saying things like you guys
are kind of finally getting the hang of
this platform and it was clear that you
were just kind of
trying a million different things just a
few months ago it's cool to read that i
mean it it it stings a little because
it's like hey you're reading our mail
you know that like but of course yeah
we're trying to figure this out but
that's what we do
as individuals as a duo as a company
what we do is we say all right what is
the next thing
how do we figure it out and we got to be
willing to get some egg on our face
by the way write that down i bet you
there's something in that like a little
egg on the face
that would be hilarious right right
in order to learn something
and um
but yeah there's lots of i mean the
things that we would try
and when it doesn't work
and you can't understand why
it's much easier to understand why to
figure out why something does work then
figure out why something didn't work you
know
uh and this is a plan even if you're
wrong about the thing that why it worked
you feel really certain why it worked
because it just the most plausible
explanation
i don't know it tends to fall into place
but then you're with the negative it's
much harder
to pinpoint it but it's so interesting
to be
working in a in a platform that you
don't know like
we've learned youtube over the course of
the time being on there so we know
in general like okay you can pitch us an
idea for a youtube video and we can tell
you that's probably not going to work
and here's why or that has a chance a
good chance of working and here's why
the principles that go into
a tick tock video
you know
title and thumbnail
are so
you know
strategic when it comes to a youtube
video because people are making a
decision in an environment where their
decision for the next video is based on
exclusively on title and thumbnail
that's not how tick-tock works right
tik-tok works on
people's reaction to the beginning of
the video whatever happens in the first
one two three seconds of the video is
how they determine if they're going to
keep watching that or swipe and then of
course that data spread across
the bunches of people who are watching
that
tell something to tick-tock which then
tells something to
uh the system and the for you page which
determines if that video is going to get
shown to more people and that's why you
can have a video that literally has 11
million views next to one that's got a
hundred thousand views on the same
channel 50 000 views right next to each
other which does not typically happen on
youtube because people's habits are
different it's a subconscious
manipulation
you're not
typically when you're scrolling you're
not making an active decision it's this
it's a passive decision that you're
hooked
so you find yourself breaking your your
scroll
because something piqued your interest
it was something you read it was
something that
you you heard that gripped you that was
irresistible
like you um and then
is that enough to keep you is the hook
set deep enough and are we are we
retaining
your
your experience keeping you from like oh
no this isn't what
this is not worthy of me stopping
scrolling i'm gonna keep going all of
that data is is is scarily insightful
um but the way that we have to interpret
it is just did it work or not did it
halfway work you there's a lot of
speculation about the algorithm but it
but it does
the more that it's about human behavior
the more that we feel like we can do
something about it right and that's
that's that's what the algorithm is
trying to do too decipher decipher human
behavior we're coming at it from from
different angles
that's a it's that's a fun challenge um
but when things don't work and then they
keep not working and maybe you've
pre-shot a whole bunch of these
that starts to get
uh disheartening and there's also oh
we've made an investment that now
is it do we know it's
like the next five that we've already
shot do we know that none of those are
going to work or is there a pivot we can
do
with text or with something else within
the tool
to
to make this still work or to prove our
to prove our theory wrong now that like
we're going down the wrong path well and
there's the challenge of not wanting to
fall into the trap which is a very
difficult thing not to do when you've
turned your
creativity into a business
and that is to just become reactive and
try to find and then your only measure
of success is if people are watching it
right now people have to watch it in
order for us to continue to feel like
it's worth doing
even though there isn't really any money
like occasion there'll be like a
sponsorship deal or whatever but there's
not a lot of money in it maybe there
will be at some point but what that what
that means is and i think it to come
back to the hazel thing for a second is
it makes the hazel
project for me that much more special
because
it really isn't a reaction to oh people
are definitely going to click on this
people are going to care about this
because of what we've learned about the
way tick tock no takes people's behavior
into account it's more like hey here's a
cool platform that seems to be
at a stage where you can still
experiment and it's not just you have to
just do this cookie cutter thing in
order to succeed
is this a place where we can throw
something up there that nobody else is
doing in exactly this way and see what
happens
again the platform isn't really
made
for
11-part series that launch all in one
night but is there something there in
this environment where it can work
to the degree where it leads to
something else within that platform
could it be part of
the platform even evolving and changing
and growing and what it's capable of
could it be that this idea and this
project and just our
uh
moving forward with it leads us to
something else that may or may not be on
tick tock
i don't know that's but that's that's
why we do things like that so that we it
it's fun to do it and it's fun in the
moment and we're proud and of it and
happy to do it
but maybe it leads to something even
more interesting and when it comes to
our
general tick tock strategy at this point
if we if we just wanted to do the stuff
that got the most views we would just
chase the trends
and
we
you know
we greg
would just be
pitching those things and every day we'd
be like let's do the next thing
but
we want to do other things as well like
that's undeniably successful
and
it it's fun and it's engaging and it
works
and that so that's exciting and
rewarding
but we also want to express ourselves
as comedians and
it is the place where we can very
quickly
um
stay unscripted and work on
work on our our character work and our
acting and our our comedic timing and
the you know the cr that craft yeah and
assert ourselves uh on that front and
say okay part of mythical's brand is
this style of comedy
something that maybe
we you used you didn't know we used to
do
but here's a reminder or an education
that we still have this type of uh
comedic work up our sleeves and now
there's a place for us to do it
strategically i think that's that's the
stars
the jury's still out on we don't know
exactly what sketches work but but we do
know we have gotten some that do work
but we do know with a few but maybe a
few exceptions
but no real big exceptions like you know
we started the mythical bits channel
which is taking the short
form stuff that we're doing for tick
tock and instagram and putting it on
youtube
and you know thank you to those of you
who are subscribed to that and are
enjoying the videos over there
but i think it's plain to see
that youtube is not the place currently
for that type of content like it's not
or maybe maybe it will maybe that maybe
it will be i mean with mythical kitchen
they were having similar conversations
and then all of a sudden one of their
shorts from months earlier
started to blow up i can't remember off
the top of my head which one it was
yeah i don't either but yeah that's the
whole short strategy for youtube youtube
is like okay listen this
genre of video this vertical short video
is obviously working it's what the kids
are into it's amazing they want to they
want to capture that audience as well
it's amazing how you can come you can
think you're coming to a conclusion this
isn't working
do we need to scrap it and then
when we were talking specifically about
our
scripted sketches on tick tock
i mean on one day
in the afternoon we were having a
conversation about like the amount of
resources we were putting into in the
amount of our time
and the lackluster performance and then
as we we were having the business
conversation
a few hours later we look on tiktok and
the latest sketch that we put up about
um
uh the favor economy and the hot sauce
like that one
took off
and it changed the our conversation
entirely because we were like hold on
we made a little tweak to the text at
the beginning of this and that and maybe
that unlocks it to be specific we put
text on screen at the beginning of the
the sketch
and we had not been doing that in the
previous ones and i'm not saying that
the sketch itself it doesn't stand on
its own and isn't relatable and that's
why people like it but
i
bet every dollar i've ever seen that the
decision to put the text at the
beginning
was the key to getting it to break out
oh yeah unless i was in previous ones it
was a discovery and it's like is that
really what it comes down to like the
people scrolling through tiktok
need to know what the sketch is about it
needs another title yeah but one not a
title it needs this is it needs context
this is making fun of this
if you're into that stop scrolling is
basically the message we're sending
so it's like this is what the joke is
going to be which is kind of a hard
thing to swallow no i would say this is
the framework
through which you can enjoy the joke
yeah and if you're into
the subject matter or what you think the
subject matter is
and now you know the framework
you're on board you are now hooked and
because i because i shared with you and
some of our friends uh uh dane dane
linda something like he's the guy who
does all the southern dad stuff yeah on
tick tock and
this dude i think he's in louisiana he's
super funny and his
voice is perfect in his mannerisms
and
he has found this success in playing
this southern
dad character
uh
and some other southern characters but
he's always just like
southern dad's meeting the neighbors
right like right he's he's got that
context through which you can be like oh
this is the context these are the jokes
within that context and that's just a
that's how tick tock is working for a
lot of people now there are some people
like pdusa who we talked about in our
very early episode about tick tock
who
he's doing something that's just so
specific
and so weird
to what to who he is
that you begin to come to expect this is
what a pd usa tick tock is it's
it's not relatable the relatable nature
of it is not why you're so you don't
need that
contextualization it's just you want to
kind of have a mind trip with this guy
whose mind is going to go anywhere but
where you think it's going to go
but for the most so we've tried some of
that just like this is just plain weird
but we just haven't found as much
success i think for that to work that
has to kind of be the only thing you got
to keep going to the same exact well and
we know we already have three categories
of things we're doing
right if all of a sudden pd started
doing trends you would be like dude
that's not cool you shouldn't you
shouldn't do trends you're cooler than
the trends yeah you you you have
superseded the you know transcended the
trends because of what who you are it's
amazing how precarious
the
the path forward is for these things and
that that's the world that we've lived
and breathed for years i mean
but it's it's fresh with tick-tock in
that we're about like we're about to
make that decision to not do sketches
anymore it we didn't quite say that but
we were about to and then the next day
it's like oh
we maybe we cracked it
you know and it then it we're shooting
more and we have we have energy and
we're
we believe in it again so it's
it's a roller coaster ride
and
that's part of what we signed up for and
then seen in the comments when something
works
where um
a lot of people say i started watching
you when i was x age and now i'm y age
and it's like a five seven or ten year
gap between those two numbers it's
tremendously encouraging that we're
reminding and recapturing an audience
that hey we're still here and we're
we're here for you
we're ready for you to come back if you
had if you'd fallen off the the mythical
wagon yeah so we remain very excited and
engaged in tick tock
uh from day to day but uh
hopefully it's just onward and upward
and i d and hopefully this hazel
experience i will always learn something
and it will always be worthwhile
but um
hopefully that's not in the context of
it just kind of flopping and being kind
of a speed bump in the story of mythical
yeah hopefully we don't look at our tick
tock uh you know channel grid and see oh
man we've got these 11 videos
in a row that all happened in this one
night and
uh we completely like what if the story
of of this is that we completely killed
our tick tock and that we sent a message
to the algorithm by sending so many
videos up in one night yeah that they
decided that no one cares anymore about
you guys and we never ever again break a
million views on tick tock and this is
going to be the super ironic episode of
beer biscuits in which
rhett and link's ambitions completely
backfired and undid everything they had
built on tick tock and then they just
shut down their channel and were never
seen again it could happen uh and you
know what that's why this is that's why
we did this it's a time capsule episode
yeah
so
let us know what you think hashtag your
biscuits i'm gonna keep the wreck on
topic here you just mentioned him
follow him on tick tock dane the great
with an extra t on the end
he's only got 1.7 million followers as
of uh
you know me reading this but
the southern dad stuff he does is so
great
and then he's he expands out to
like
southern mechanic ac repairman but the
southern mechanic if you drill back into
that
oh that's great too but the dad is just
amazing southern school bus drivers be
like if you grew up where we grow 6.8
million views
you the moment he goes into his
character is just like man i knew so
many people he
this is an amalgamation of so many
people that we knew and i can't even
explain how relatable it is yeah dane
the great with an extra t hey dane we're
big fans
let's hang out you and your tattoos up
your neck and down your arms maybe we'll
get some neck tattoos on and still
becoming the southern dad with the neck
tattoos
i love it let's get a neck tattoo
together dane
okay well maybe you two can alright well
great
we'll talk next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best